it's time for one of the most called for
segments ever on the show and that's
sound effects theater and we have we're
going to do sound effects theater now
yeah this is where you know sona and i
typically will act out a scene and you
will provide the sound effects but using
only spoken word yes this is an
innovation i came up with uh that i'm
very proud of wow you're proud of it
very proud of it where instead of going
to all the time in trouble on a podcast
of recreating a sound effect why not
just
say what the sound is oh that sounds
cool yeah oh and let me also explain
that's a special episode
yeah um guests never hang around for
this part oh and i don't know why you're
still here i went downstairs during the
break and someone has stolen my mountain
bike so
that's
weird we are here and we're we had this
wonderful interview uh with flula yeah
and then uh
he leaves and
then we start doing this part of the
show and i notice he's back in
the recording room again
there's a chair in here
it's air conditioned do you not own a
chair at home well not outside on the
pavement okay
i just ordered another bicycle on prime
all right well uh
wow
we've never done this before oh okay uh
we've never had the
guests hang out like this but i know you
i know that you will be very unobtrusive
while we do uh sound effects uh theater
and um you know just try not to touch
any of the buttons here okay any of the
knobs like this one no no don't touch
that one okay just
fire a missile okay all right um all
right let's uh we're gonna do sound
effects theater now where i create uh my
version of uh sound effects and this is
my gift to the podcast world
radio um you know any anything where you
only have the audio it's my gift yeah
nice all right movies could use this too
yeah yeah go ahead yeah okay um so let's
do let's do we're at a zoo this time how
about that okay
all right
[Music]
as the new hires here at the cincinnati
zoo we have a lot of work to do to get
to cleaning up these cages first of all
how are you two today um i'm doing great
i'm really excited about animals uh
thank you matt for hiring me i hope to
save enough money to purchase another
mountain bike soon smart i like you kid
you got a good head on your shoulders
thank you adult
uh-oh looks like the baboons are acting
up
[Music]
acting up the monkeys are speaking yeah
i'm gonna need you to sedate them uh
they get a little too uh excited
sometimes
great shoot them with the tranquilizer
dart here stop moving baboon
trigger through air
skill secret got you baboon don't die oh
no
morg you killed our showcase baboon oh
no i'm so dead yet
well he's dying let me apply cpu better
oh better oh okay i was going to make
out with him and pump his rumpus or what
is it what's that meant
interlock yeah
compressor compressor compressor heart
to beat the heart to beat the heart to
beat the heart
yeah you did it
wow
shoot again shoot
oh no i've accidentally murdered the
baboon bleed bleed bleed bleed bleed
bleed bleed bleed bleed bleed bleed
please help me sona employee why did we
give a trainee a real gun i don't
understand why that happened i've never
learned how to do it i figured he's as
good as anyone else and now listen we've
excited the elephants trunk blow noises
jesus drunk blue noise stop running at
me big big one
it's all football football football
rattle fumble round fumble footfall
football trunk blown eyes
sona quick jump on this one all right
i'm jumping on him to damon
land back
the only way to do it is for one of us
to do a very accurate tarzan yell okay
um
is that accurate no not at all we're
gonna have to try again oh sorry um
jungle yeah
i'm looking for that kind of pitch
shifting you know tarzan yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah we have a yellow swing on
vine yeah i knew my yodeling would come
in handy you're welcome everyone all
right well that's taken care of now we
just need to go over here to the lion
den
oh we're walking
we're loud walkers are the muppets here
fossee bear bossy what are you doing
here key insert twist
why are we opening the lion area you
know honestly i did not intend to but i
i just just happened and here we are
inside the lion den so and here comes
leo
he's not well oh
the lion is just saying lion
wow he looks like a descendant of
chewbacca a little bit speak some more
you hot hot flying
hungry oh here let me get my chapstick
out of my fanny and zip moisturize you
hand over
wow you've been a real good leo here
here's a big t-bone steak hand
state
[Music]
mmm nice i want to eat some of that as
well leo choo choo choo masticate
swallow
digest
wow delicious
i love you
i love you i love you he loves you wow
her feelings are not reciprocated oh
no rejection has the sound effects oh
count me out i quit this terrible job
matt i don't blame you i quit as well
this place is full of hate
sona oh i'll quit too oh yeah i was
gonna say yeah yeah yeah i'm quitting
too cause you i don't want to do this
alone the end
oh my god